what's going on guys this is rob and
let's talk about the post credit scene
of doctor strange two and by extension
talk about the future of the mcu right
what direction things are going in here
so here's the funny thing about this i
think everybody's understanding of what
causes incursions is kind of right but
also wrong at the same time so here's
the first thing and this is the question
that i imagine a lot of people have what
exactly are incursions okay so we have
an explanation for that in a couple
different videos the first one is over a
comments explained we've got a video
just dedicated to explaining the
incursions which you'll find a link to
you in the description but we also have
the entire coverage of jonathan
hickman's avengers and new avengers uh
which you'll also find in the the
description as well right it's the full
nine hour like breakdown of the whole
thing right everything from the
beginning when black panther discovers
the first incursion all the way up to
the end of secret wars 2015. it was a
huge and just phenomenal amazing event i
loved it uh i even even to this day i go
back and read it again but the nature of
incursions are essentially that it's
realities bumping into each other and
earth is effectively the anchor point
and so if both earth collide both
realities will be destroyed but if you
destroy one of the earth's that the the
two universes will pass right through
each other and nothing will happen as we
were told by john krasinski's reed
richards in doctor strange too that's
exactly what the doctor strange of the
illuminati universe earth 838 that's
what he did that he basically invoked
the power of the darkhold and in doing
so caused an incursion and in causing an
incursion he basically destroyed the
alternate reality which killed billions
of lives and because of that the
illuminati executed him and so what this
seems to indicate is that use of the
dark hold causes an incursion but the
question you have to ask is why i mean
we don't really have a lot of
information about the dark hole that's
seemingly incontinuity in the mcu
there's a lot of things that involve the
dark hole over the course of different
shows and so on that have been produced
under the banner of marvel but we don't
know whether or not those are in
continuity similarly because the dark
hole actually looks different in those
those different situations we could
possibly bring those in but the only
real explanation that we have assuming
that we only go by what we've seen in
the movies is what wong told scarlet
witch when he said that like the dark
hold is basically a copy right the book
itself is a copy of the original text
which is in mount wondergore and it was
used by the first demon to ever practice
black magic this idea of the darkhold
causing incursions is seemingly
confirmed by two other things the first
is when the marvel cinematic universe
basically earth 616 stephen strange
would that's that's really going to get
confusing when you're talking about the
comics versus the movies but that
seemingly confirmed when the main marvel
cinematic universe stephen strange meets
with that alternate reality counterpart
in the dissolving reality who would use
the dark hold and what we were seeing in
terms of that universe falling apart is
the result of what happens when an
incursion actually takes place we don't
know how far reaching that is right we
don't know uh we didn't really see an
alternate earth out there in the sky not
that i'm aware of it was literally just
his reality falling apart but seemingly
it was caused by him using the dark hole
and he readily admitted it and then you
also had the post-credits scene where
khalia popped up to stephen strange and
said you caused an incursion by using
the dark hold like you have to you know
come with me or something along those
lines and so it's kind of an interesting
set of events because it seems like the
dark hold causes incursions but i'm not
a hundred percent sure that's correct i
mean we could literally just be taking
two things and creating a corollary
where none exists
but i think i think incursions are a
result of loki if i'm being honest with
you guys i mean maybe it's not right
maybe it really is the dark hole i mean
from what we've seen
everybody who uses the dark hold seems
to cause an incursion but one of the
things that was also solidified and i
feel like it flew under the radar and i
feel like a lot of people didn't
necessarily notice it that in the the
illuminati universe for example what
that essentially established is that in
every reality and we even saw in the
what if episode when like thanos showed
up on earth and was destroyed by uh by
ultron or in the marvel zombies universe
when he showed up and then was turned
into a zombie that in every universe
across the multiverse thanos always goes
for the infinity gauntlet and
essentially the events of infinity war
basically always play out and we knew
that from like infinity war right when
literally doctor strange watches or
looks through 14 million possibilities
14 million alternate realities and only
finds one where they succeed and that's
just the sacred timeline that's not
accounting for all the rest of the
multiverse that was out there that the
sacred timeline was separated from
that's something to keep in mind is that
the time of infinity war he who remains
still existed right he was still alive
so we weren't really part of the main
multiverse proper which seems to
indicate that according to doctor
strange there were 14 million realities
that all led to he who remains but
nonetheless i digress the important
thing here is that those things always
play out the same way and so what that
would seem to indicate is that if doctor
strange looked at all these different
realities and saw all these different
situations where the only one in which
they won is the one where basically tony
stark had to sacrifice his life then
there had to be alternate realities out
there where the dark hold was invoked
and never caused an incursion because
you would think if that was the case
that stephen strange would have been
like okay we do win in some of these but
we kind of lose too because basically
reality ends because of an incursion or
something along those lines but i have a
hard time believing that wouldn't be a
possibility that he would acknowledge
right he probably would have gone the
way of earth 838 stephen strange and
said look we'll defeat thanos in the
present will obliterate that alternate
earth and that'll basically be it what i
think is going on here is i think you
might be looking at something a kindle
like a coinkink right a coincidence that
the incursions are not really a result
of a person using the darkhold it looks
that way but i don't necessarily think
that's the case i think what's actually
going on here is incursions are a result
of the events of loki now again i have
no real evidence to support this largely
because we don't know enough about the
incursions to even create any kind of
reasonable argument at this point it's
all just theories based on what we think
you know and what information we have in
the comics but the point that i'm making
here is that in the comics incursions
happen because a singular event led to
the explosion of a reality which caused
the realities next to it to bump into
the realities next to them that
explosion pushed the realities next to
them into the realities next to them and
so on and so forth until
basically you had the engine of the
giant incursion event right the mass
destruction of the multiverse a single
event is what causes that a single event
is what creates the collapse of the
multiverse through incursions now as far
as i'm aware when it comes to the
dealings of the multiverse and a
singular event that would lead to
realities crashing into each other
that sounds like loki right if you guys
remember at the end of the loki tv
series that when when he who remains was
killed and loki himself was sent back to
the the tva headquarters that when he
arrived there that basically kang had
already conquered everything right kang
had taken the opportunity for the death
of of he who remains to essentially
seize control of the sacred timeline
once it rejoined the rest of the
multiverse and all these different
realities were just coming out of
existence right you guys saw that like
just everything just just spinning out
of everything else but it was complete
and total madness there was no
organization there was no structure it
was just all over the place and as a
result of that literally you saw
universes crossing paths with each other
right just crossing over across each
other and through each other and all
kinds of different stuff that looks
exactly the way an incursion event would
happen right i mean at least according
to the mcu the way it's done in mobile
comics incursion when it came to the
incursions one of the things to know is
that the multiverse is a highly
intricate and organized thing this has
kind of been established over the years
by different stories or somebody saying
something but the best illustration of
it came during hickman's avengers new
avengers when hank pym ant-man was sent
into the multiverse to find the source
of the incursions and the way that he
explained the function or at least the
form of the multiverse is that it was
just a linear series of universes all
sitting next to each other right just
kind of residing right next to each
other stretching on seemingly for
infinity and so again that's the reason
why those incursions worked out the way
they did pushing universes into the
universes next to them but the
multiverse is organized literally what
happened at the end of loki was the
total annihilation of the organizational
structure of the multiverse if ever
there were a a literal indication of
what a series of incursive events would
look like it's what we saw at the end of
loki and even foggy came out and said
okay so essentially the plot of doctor
strange too is a direct result of what
happened with loki i have to believe
that includes incursions it includes
like incursive events maybe the timing
is just one of those things right maybe
it's just kind of a timing thing uh
because again we don't know exactly how
much time had passed we don't know
exactly what all went on with steven
strange in terms of his corruption how
far how extensive his use of the dark
hold was that led to an incursion event
but i can't really think of any
circumstances whereby using a book
composed of black magic would create an
incursion i could see where it would
violate multiversal law i mean what
happened in doctor strange too if ever
there were a time for the living
tribunal to intervene that would be it
because wanda basically dream walking
into other realities that immediately
violates like multiversal law that's a
big no-no you're not supposed to do that
and so if the living tribunals form and
function in the marvel cinematic
universe matched his form and function
in the comics he would have immediately
stepped in there literally would have
been no plot wanda would have done that
for the first time like before the movie
even started right when you had like
steven strange the the ulcerative steven
strange and america chavez running from
the monster that was summoned by uh
wanda literally like the living tribunal
would have wiped that thing out of
existence and then it would have
appeared to wanda and said if you do
this again i'll destroy you and your
entire reality and if she really wanted
to be an idiot she would have fought the
living tribunal which would have
destroyed her and then he would have
been like when you mess with the bull
you get the horns what happened in that
movie was just flouting
magical multiversal law
but i can't really think of how using a
dark hold would create like a universal
or any kind of multiversal in cursive
event uh now again that's because we
don't necessarily know a whole lot about
the incursions but i feel like what's
going on here is more of people just not
understanding what's actually going on
not fully grasping what's happening
because that's the thing like in
hickman's avengers and new avengers
nobody knew what was happening right off
the bat i mean like technically the
illuminati did but they never told
anybody nobody else out there knew about
the incursions captain america did but
as soon as he objected to them wiping
out whole worlds to save their universe
dr strange wiped his mind and threw him
out of the illuminati so he just he
never remembered anything about it all
they knew is that you literally had like
magical beings from other realities or
you had aliens from other sectors of
space who were literally fleeing to
earth because that's where the most
powerful people are and it was a place
of protection nobody really knew what
was going on and then of course the
builders show up and you end up learning
you know they're there to destroy earth
because of the multiverse but in effect
earth superheroes were like the last
ones to learn about the multiversal
collapse like they were the last ones to
know that like earth is the anchor point
the incursions are happening and
realities are collapsing like here comes
the clue train superheroes the last stop
is you that's literally what it was
and so taking all that logic from the
comics and applying it to the movies it
wouldn't surprise me one bit if the
illuminati's hypothesis on the
incursions and the dark hole being a
source of it that's completely wrong and
it wouldn't surprise me if basically no
one actually knows what's happening
because essentially no one knows that
kang is out there and no one knows about
the events of loki i think this whole
thing would set the stage for what's
going on with uh with loki season two i
think that lucky season two it'd be
great if it focused heavily on like the
entire incursions event and how what's
going on here is a result of the death
of he who remains how silvie killing he
who remains didn't simply just you know
eliminate or somehow fix or correct the
sacred timeline or whatever her
motivation was that that motivation
escapes me that it's actually leading to
just the collapse of the multiverse she
made a big no-no right she did a big
oopsie
again i think that'd be cool i think
that's that's really the bigger picture
here and then everybody else is just
kind of wrong they're just literally
haphazard guessing or they're reading
the information incorrectly so let me
know what you guys think down in the
comments section right you guys think
this is really what's going on here that
the dark hold is not actually the cause
of the incursions it's just people think
it is or do you think it really is the
dark hold i don't know let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace